Marvel Studios is planning on many
different characters entering the MCU in
the next couple of phases and the
characters that we are hearing about are
super exciting and one of the main ones
is Ghost Rider now in yesterday's video
we went over a lot we talked about
future projects both movies and shows
special presentations and of course
characters coming to the MCU and there
are just so many right now and there's
so much to be excited about however I
saw some very specific questions about
some very specific Heroes yesterday so I
wanted address them in this video so in
this video we'll go over the midnight
Suns and new characters coming to that
team the cosmic side of the MCU and a
little bit about the X-Men the very
first new X-Men team in the MCU plus a
few bonuses as well also big reminder
about our giveaway only two days left so
for a chance to win a PS5 and Xbox
series X some Marvel Legends items or
some DC items all you have to do is
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment down below the winner gets to
pick one item and we pick one winner at
the end of each month and yes we are
going to continue doing these giveaways
each month next year in 2024 as well
plus a few other giveaway opportunities
as well so stay tuned so like I
mentioned the first one I want to
address is Ghost Rider previously we had
a lot of reports talking about how
Marvel Studios did have plans to
introduce Ghost Rider into the MCU via a
special presentation on Disney plus so
basically have a story just like
werewolf by night that introduced who we
are assuming was going to be Johnny
Blaze especially since we had that
little Donnie Blaze teaser Cameo joke
whatever you want to call it in She-Hulk
now this originally was the plan however
here is the problem since then a lot has
changed but before you panic no we are
not saying that Ghost Rider is not
coming to the MCU he just may not come
in a special presentation anymore but
that could actually be a good thing let
me explain these reports about Ghost
Rider getting his own Disney Plus show
happened before Disney and Marvel
Studios kind of re-evaluated what they
were were doing with their movies and
most importantly Disney plus content
most people know that Bob Iger and Kevin
fuggy both spoke out and said that they
were simply producing too much content
and they were going to scale back
meaning they aren't going to make as
many Disney Plus shows as they were
before and maybe not as many movies per
year as they planned on doing for
example they planned on doing three to
four movies a year which was a big step
up from what they were doing before plus
not to mention they were busting out
like five to six Disney plus projects a
year and they already admitted trying to
do all of this was just too much and
they were spread too thin and in some
projects in movies and shows we saw the
quality lack so Marvel Studios is now
kind of changing things up so we are
unsure right now if Ghost Rider is going
to be getting his own Disney plus
special presentation still however what
we are still pretty sure about is that
Marvel Studios does still have plans to
introduce him in the MCU and we've even
heard talks recently that Marvel Studios
might be doing doing limited series
meaning they aren't going to be as long
as full 6 episode 9 episode Disney Plus
shows but they won't just be one special
presentation that's 45 minutes to an
hour and a half long they're going to be
probably one to two to three episodes
that are about 45 minutes to an hour and
a half long specifically focusing on a
character or a story so there is a good
chance that Marvel Studios might choose
to do that with Ghost Rider if not we
have been hearing that there are plans
to introduce him as a part of the
midnight Suns team because Marvel
Studios is going to be exploring that
team in the MCU relatively soon we've
already started it with W div Vision
Multiverse of Madness Agatha coven of
chaos and we're going further into it
with iron heart where Mesto is
supposedly going to be introduced plus
not to mention blade and hopefully Ghost
Rider makes his way in there as well in
fact Marvel Studios has recently met
with Ryan goling now we've heard the
report but we haven't heard exactly
which character they met with him him
about and in reality they probably met
with him about multiple characters
because that's what Marvel typically
does and right now the best guesses we
have for who he's going to be playing is
either Ghost Rider or the person we'll
talk about next Nova and you can go
ahead and let us know who you'd prefer
to see him play in the comments down
below now Nova is going to be a part of
the cosmic side of the MCU which Kevin
fagia said that they are going to really
start to explore and we do have our new
Guardians of the Galaxy team and right
now fans are hoping that Nova is going
to go on to be a part of the Guardians
of the Galaxy team that way he can
really be involved with all of the
cosmic Adventures that are about to take
place in the next few phases of the MCU
and of course further on we're hoping
that he will go on to join the current
team that consists of Rocket Raccoon
Groot kraglin Cosmo Adam Warlock and
phel Nova would be a really great
addition and I think would get the
people even more excited for this new
Guardians of the Galaxy team in fact I
think he could be the person who takes
over the place of Star-Lord now another
team that's coming to the MCU of course
is the Fantastic 4 and we briefly went
over this yesterday but we don't really
know too much about the movie yet
besides the fact that the movie's
villains are going to be a female Herald
for Galactus and of course Galactus
himself they don't have plans for Doom
really being a part of the movie if Doom
is a part of it he'll most likely only
be a cameo for a brief time and I'm
talking a few seconds not minutes and
then the kicker is this movie might take
place in another universe but we know
that the 616 universe most likely isn't
going to be the main Universe after
Avengers Secret Wars going into the soft
MCU reboot so this fantastic 14 team
will end up being the main Fantastic
Four team of the MCU going forward with
whatever the main universe is they are
going to be in it so the Fantastic Four
team that is coming relatively soon is
the main Fantastic 4 team that we'll see
for years to come then we have our
Avengers teams Now The Avengers teams
might start to get split up into
different categories that's what Kevin
is making it sound like we'll have
the street level Avengers team which is
looking honestly pretty exciting we're
going to have Spider-Man the new Captain
America Sam Wilson She-Hulk Daredevil
and the Scarlet Witch is returning
however we've heard that she is going to
be a part of the midnight Suns team so I
don't think she's going to be on the
street level team and we also have Bruce
Banner however he might belong to
another team that's going to be in the
MCU and that is going to be team Hulk
now we've talked about World War Hulk
several times now and it looks like
Marvel Studios really is is setting up
the MCU to have a lot of different hulks
in it so at some point in time we are
going to have a team of Hulks going up
against a bad team of Hulks what we're
about to see in the MCU and what we've
already really seen in the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier is that the super
soldier program is still happening super
soldier Serum is still being given to
people and according to the latest
Insider reports Thunderbolt Ross wants
the hulks blood Bruce Banner's blood or
she-hulk's blood because he wants to be
able to handle gamma radiation which
Bruce Banner and She-Hulk can do so
ultimately that is what world war Hulk
is going to be our good hulks Bruce
Banner shehulk his son scar maybe a
couple others that they could introduce
and bad ones like Red Hulk and the other
experiments gone bad that they create
then we have the Thunderbolts who really
are a team of their own but the
Thunderbolts movie is really important
because it's going to introduce Sentry
into the MCU and according to The
Insider my time to shine hello centy is
going to be every bit as powerful as he
is in the comics in fact she stated the
better question is what can't he do and
for the comic book fans who are
wondering about this we have heard that
the void is indeed going to be a part of
century being introduced into the MCU so
we're really looking forward to that
then we have the X-Men now according to
Insider my time to shine hello the new
MCU mutants will be a new X-Men team and
this is important to note because at
some point in time we were all kind of
confused on on whether or not the new
X-Men team was going to consist of new
and old X-Men like Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine sticking around and being a
part of the new team there was some
confusion there and make no mistake Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine is sticking around
for Avengers Secret Wars but we will
have films and projects that will
introduce a new X-Men team and no old
X-Men from any other previous universe
will be a part of this team when they
introduce these mutants into the MCU
they are going to be New Mutants new
characters who will be the new new X-Men
team of the future of the MCU so just a
bit of clarification there because the
X-Men and the Fantastic Four they really
are the future of the MCU and they
really are going to be all new cast all
new characters really just a fresh start
for the MCU once we get the soft reboot
moving forward and another part of the
future of the MCU of course last but not
least is the Young Avengers Marvel
basically made an official announcement
that the Young Avengers are coming in
the Marvels at the very end we saw
Kamala Khan talking to Kate Bishop she
also asked did you know that Ant-Man had
a daughter so this is very clearly
setting up the Young Avengers team and I
hope they do this before Secret Wars
because I hope we get a very specific
King variant which is iron lad I know a
lot of people have been talking about
him showing up we haven't heard anything
really about him showing up however I
think if they didn't put him in a Young
Avengers project if it happened before
Secret Wars it would be a huge missed
opportunity but as you can see we have
many different groups that are about to
make up the new Marvel Cinematic
Universe and things are very exciting so
go ahead and let us know which group you
are most excited about in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter as well
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof